مساء الفل ازيكم انا مهندس معماري
اتخرجت سنه 2000
وبحب اكسبلور حاجات مختلفه
كنت بصور وانا في الجامعه واتخرجت من
الجامعه كملت تصوير وقفت شويه وبعدين رجعت
تاني وهكذا
او بالادق الاكسبرش اعتقد ان احنا كبني
ادمين
يمكن كل واحد عنده طريقه مختلفه للتعبير
عن نفسه
ودي حاجه عظيمه جدا واعتقد برضو ان احنا
ممكن يبقى عندنا الاحتياج للتعبير باشياء
مختلفه كبني ادم واحد ممكن حد يكون بيغني
وبيكتب وبيمثل وبيرسم و ابريشيات حاجات
تانيه كثيره حواليها
اكسبرس اور سيلفس انا قعدت اصور الشارع
كثير قوي
تصوير الشارع كان ملهم جدا جدا بالنسبه لي
لان الشارع بيحصل فيه كل حاجه
بتاع الشارع دايما بينقل المجتمع بابعاده
كلها وبعد شويه
طبيعه شغلي وزيارات المواقع
وكل الالمنس المكونه للنايم تو فايف
بتاعتي ابتديت اخد وانقل اللغه بتاعتي في
التصويرمنت لان انا انتمي للبيلت ان
دراستي تنتمي الى
علاقه السبيسيز بالبشر كلها حاجات
صيني سانشيل في حياتنا اليوميه
انا لسه جاي من
وقد ايه العلاقات يعني في ديزاينر كانت
عامله مع سيكولوجيست علشان يشوفوا علاقه
سبيس بتاعه البني ادم احنا كاركتكس
هودي يوزر والفيل اخدت تجربه التصوير دي
ونقلتها جوه
من اول الحاجات اللي خبطتني
رسومات العمال اللي على الحيطان احنا كبني
ادمين وهو ده الهدف من الطاقه النهارده
بطرق مختلفه اوكي
كلنا بنسيب ورانا سواء من 4000 سنه فبتحكي
لنا قصه المصري القديم او تريسيز عمرها
ثلاث شهور وهتختفي بعد يومين لان الحيطه
دي هتدهن التريسس دي بتحكي قصه العامل
اللي موجود هناك في ثلاث انواع عمال في
عامل بيكتب رقم تليفونه وعامل بيكتب
ايه قرانيه وعامل بيرسم اللي بيرسم ده ليه
مش فنان فنبتدي نسال نفسنا
هو الكيف مان لما رسم من 30,000 سنه جوه
الكهف كان بيرسم عشان يعبر عن نفسه هو
بيرجع انا النهارده اصطدت غزاله انا
النهارده اكتشفت النار وبيعملها
هو كان عايز يعبر عايز يدوكيمنت عايز يحكي
قصته كلنا عايزين نحكي قصتنا كلنا عايزين
نلف
الانستجرام
بعد 20 30 سنه
هتتفرجوا على حاجات انا كنت بعمل كده وانا
عندي 18 سنه كنت بلبس كده ياه كنت باكل
كده وهكذا العامل ده له
الجزء الاكبر من القصه هنا هو اللي كان
بيتفتح مع بتاعي
بيستفز يقول لي كريم هو انت مش مركز في
الهندسه هو انت ما سبت الهندسه ومركز في
التصوير هو انت ايه اللي بتصوره دي شويه
خربشه على الحيطه فنفتح كونفرسيشن مقصود
من ناحيتي ان اقول له لا ده فن فيستفز
اكتر اقول له اه فن ليه مش فن هو ايه الفن
لا لا ده اكيد مش فن ده شويه خربشه طب
اشرح لي الفن يعطل مش قادر يعبر عن الفن
لان مفهوم الفن كبير قوي الفن هو انتوشن
هو احتياج للتعبير عن النفس هو عمل بحث
طويل المدى عشان الواحد يعرف هو عايز يقول
ايه في الاخر
العامل ده ببساطه الشوك جوينج دي رسم رسمه
عبر عن نفسه حقق اكبر
مكونه للعمل الفني الا وهو سلفلس اللي
بيعمل فن بيعمله عشان هو عايز يعمله مش
عشان عايز يبه ومش عشان عايز يبيع طبعا من
حقه يبهر حد ومن حقه يبيع ومن حقه كل حاجه
في الدنيا بس في الاخر بيبقى عنده طاقه او
شحنه محتاجه تخرج العامل ده قدر يعبر عن
نفسه بهذه البساطه من اللحظه دي اكتشفت ان
انا هيبقى شغلي الشاغل ما يفوكس والبي ان
علاقه مخارج سور الكومباوند ومداخل سور
الكومباوند علاقه العامل اللي بيزور
الكومباوند او ريزيدانش الاريا او او
لفتره وجيزه لفتره محدده من الزمن وبيخرج
بيسيب ايه اثر وراه فقعدت سنه الصور دي
فوجود ماي كلاينس فبالتالي نفتح فنتناقش
في مفهوم الفن بيت اي حد فينا بنقدر نعرف
صاحب هذا البيت من الكتب اللي بيقراها في
المكتبه ومن الصور اللي محطوطه قدامه صح
هخش اقول ايه ده نوع الفن اللي بيحطه كذا
اه ده بيحب الفوتوغرافيا اه ده بيحط ايات
قرانيه اه ده بيحط صور عيلته اه ده بيقرا
في الفن بيقرا في السياسه بيقرا في كذا طب
تقدري تشكلي فريم بسيط قوي حوالين صاحب
هذا المكان من خلال مقتنياته هنا ده كان
جزء مهم
ده مشروع تاني البيوت فيلبنس كان فيها
مشكله
بتهبط
الارض مش
مدروسه مضبوط فقعدت سنه اصور الكراكس اللي
فيارمنت اللي انا بشتغل فيه
وعملت بيه البيستي زي ما انتم شايفين خيطت
كل التراكس اللي موجوده في في المبنى
وكتبت بهم كده الخروج من وسط البلد النزاع
والخروج من وسط البلد كله بيخرج للمناطق
اللي بره القاهره عشان الزحمه فدستثمار
لكن
ازاي وسط البلد سبينج استرتش طالعه براها
ده مهم قوي بقى دي قصه بالنسبه لي في غايه
الاهميه
وانا ماشي كل اللي انتم شايفينه ده لو
تاخدوا بالكم هو ترجمه السوشيال ثرو البلت
انفرمت هو جواز الفكرتين لبعض هو انا
انتمي لدراسه بدراستي للبلت
بشكل مباشر بشوف السوشيال ده معكوس ازاي
على المبنى دورنا كلنا نبص حوالينا ونبقى
اللي موجوده في المدرسه او في الجامعه مين
كتب ايه ايه اللي كان بيتكتب في الوقت ده
طب ده بيعبر عن ايه طيب اللي بيخربش في
العربيه ده بيخربش في طب موجوده في كل
المناطق ولا بتتعمل في شكل معين طب بتتعمل
في عربيات معينه على العربيات لا ف
فتبتدوا دي كونستراكت الانفارمنت اللي
حواليكم لما الواحد بيفك المكونات لاشياء
صغيره بيقدر يفهمه لما تاخذوا الايفون كذا
تفكوه تك تك ايه ده ده تعرفي تبني واحد
جديد اندرستان
تكسروا فيه كذا حتت صغيره تفردوها قدامكم
وتقولوا اه والله ده
ريكونستراكتد هجيب دي هنا وهجيب دي هنا
وهاحط دي قبل دي هيطلع شكل مختلف
كنت ماشي دخلت جامع السلطان الغوري ولقيت
السجاجيد عشوائيه جدا ما فيش سجاده شبه
التانيه فسالت فقالوا لي اه دي السجاجيد
بيتبرع بيها اهل المنطقه
كان شيء عظيم جدا ان السلطان الغوري جامع
العتيق
المهم
سجاجيده اصلا عشوائيه شيء بيعكس حاجه
بيعكس انه الناس بتحبه بيعكس انه ما فيش
نظام
بيعكس انه في حب
قعدت اصور اربع سنين صور كده
انا هنا انا هنا مش في مش مهم المهم هنا
هو
الروح والفكره بتاعت البني ادم اللي قرر
يتبرع بسجاده من بيتهم يتبرك بها يروح
لامام الجامع يقول له خد دي فامام الجامع
يتحول للكريتور لمنسق ياخد السجاده دي
يقوم حاططها فوق هنا والسجاده دي حاططها
كده والسجاده دي حاططها السجاجيد دي جايه
مشحونه اصلا بطاقه اصحابها يعني السجاده
اللي كانت في الطرقه اللي حصل مش عارف ايه
السجاده الليفنج روم اللي وقع عليها
مكرونه وشهدت على خناق وحب وزعيق واطفال
كده زي ما هي قبلت السجاده بتاعه حد من
الجيران جنبها من غير ما يعرفوا بعض
تقابلوا في الجامع بقوا سجدتين جداد بشكل
مختلف الفكره دي لما شفتها تفهم اولا
مفهوم الجمال مفهوم الجمال مش انه حلو او
وحش لان حلو او وحش دي نسبيه مفهوم الجمال
هي النيه اللي عنده النيه للتجميل فهو في
حد ذاته جميل كل واحد عنده نيه مختلفه كل
واحد عنده فكره مختلفه عن الجمال نقطه
حاليا بعد ما خدت بالي ان انا عايز افضل
الالمنس الصغيره المكونه بقيت عارف بدور
على ايه اول ما بلاقيشن هتحكي قصه بقوم
رايح واخدها كده وعامل زوم ان عليها كده
بالميكروسكوب كده عشان افضل اوصل لاخرها
افكها وافضل اركبها جنب بعض تاني فتحتي
قصه النهارده قادر احكي قصص مختلفه جوه
البلت انفارمنت عشان اعبر بيها عن السوشل
من خلال الالمنس دي حاليا انا منبهر
بالمكان بتاع المراتب بتاعت غفير البيت
اللي تحت التشطيب لانه بياخد المرتبه
يحطها في حته معينه جدا الحته دي مش اوسع
حته في البيت ولا احلى حته في البيت ومع
انه عنده القدره والامكانيه هو البيت ده
بتاعه لمده ست شهور او تسع شهور بتتغالي
مكلف الى اخره
ولكن هو بيختار الدفا بيختار يحطه يحط
مرتبته وينام يا اما تحت السلم يا اما في
حمام يا اما في مخزن صغير مفهوم البيت
الحقيقي هو الدفى هو ان الواحد يبقى فيه
احتواء
ان البيت يبقى كبير وفخم وحلو فهنا انا
بلعب على الحته دي ايه هو مفهوم البيت هل
البيت هو الحجم هل البيت هو
الفخامه هل البيت هو الذوق هل البيت هو
الذكريات هل البيت كل كل مكونات البيت
وهعكي القصه دي من خلال مراتب في الاخر
لقصه اكبر دايما بيتقال انه
انشوايد انا مايل دي الواحد لما بيلاقي
انش ضيق كده وينزل جواه لغايه اخره بيلاقي
حاجه مهمه قوي الوايت انجل دي كلنا
بنشوفها زي بعض كلكم شايفين الفيو ده
تقريبا زي بعض وانا شايفكم كلكم في انجل
في فريم واحد انما لو قربت ورحت في زاويه
ضيقه قوي هنا هشوف فريم خالص هبقى حابب
احكي لكم قصه وممكن اقول لكم في مايك هنا
اهو وفيشه ممكن اصوره لكم واحكيها لكم
فيبتدي يطلع هنا حاجه شخصيه الحاجه
الشخصيه دي بتخلينا كلنا نشوف مواضيع
مختلفه
انا هفضل مركز جوه البلت انفارمنت افكه
افردهم جنب بعض وارجع كونستراكتدم بطريقه
يبقى فيها ناريتيف تحكي قصه العشرين سنه
اللي انا بشتغل فيها ثانكيو
[تصفيق]